you know I originally auditioned to be
you you made this joke a long time ago
did I yeah I read it at that video it's
better now then that's not better
we're gonna watch today from Screen Rant
Marvel actors who audition for other MCU
roles and before we hop into this I just
wanted to say this wallet I've been
using has just been falling apart okay
John what I'm trying to say is thank you
to Rage for sponsoring this video
No why don't you just say that it's
called a natural segue dude
it didn't feel natural okay then you
have something that feels more natural
yeah I do I've been rocking mine for
about a year now in my pockets haven't
had a problem since yeah when they sent
me over this titanium matte black wallet
and it's way better than my last wallet
goodbye to that wallet cuz these wallets
are super light and durable they hold up
to 12 cards and come with your choice of
strap or money clip for your cash there
are more than 30 colors and designs to
choose from including
carbon fiber and burnt titanium and
they're all made with RFID blocking
technology to keep your cards safe the
wallet is efficient cuts down on bulk
and fits just about anywhere you know
who would love receiving one of these
rigid wallets which has over 30,000
five-star reviews who your dad now
that's a segue but Father's Day coming
up rich is offering a special discount
sale where you can get 10% off free
worldwide shipping and returns by the
way all you have to do is go to Ridge
comm slash reject nation again that's
Ridge comps less reject nation one more
time Ridge mcoms last reject nation I
think they get it
yeah but do they know the code I'm
assuming it's reject nation that's the
code he was gonna get it wrong link in
description box peeps and surprise your
dad or treat yourself of one of these
Ridge wallets today
[Music]
at this point it's almost like every
single big-name actor in Hollywood is
linked to a specific comic-book
superhero or villain in the movie Carrie
luckiest to land a role in the MCU which
for all intents and purposes is the king
of a hill when it comes to superhero
movies all burn actors were lucky enough
to land the role of a lifetime while
others had to deal with getting told no
and probably venturing over to DC or
something shots taken when the MCU and
got it only not the road they were
auditioning for I went through a phase
of just doing self tapes on to self
station on self tape yeah that's right
DMC under Shepard Thor today could have
been very different if Disney at me I
know they are distinct choices local
movies now actually try it out to play a
different role
can you imagine what things would have
been like if chadwick boseman was
someone other than T'Challa or if
another one of the Chris Evans audition
for Black Panther to try it out for
different roles Chris Pratt as Captain
America it's tough to imagine now
because everyone knows Chris Evans is
Captain America and Chris Pratt is
star-lord but those weren't the original
plans originally auditioned for the role
of Captain America several years before
he landed the role of Peter quill again
this was a while before guardians of the
galaxy eventually came to fruition while
Pratt was still just getting started in
Parks and Recreation oh yes he ran
dramatic roles either such as Moneyball
or zero dark thirty he didn't land the
part but he made enough of an impression
to remain on the mind of the casting
director saw that matters when you're
acting in two Guardians director James
Gunn for the part of Starro interests a
good thing that things worked out this
way because Pratt's hilarious
personality went way better with the
Peter quill character and Chris Evans as
clean-cut wholesome imaged paired
perfectly with America's hero Steve
Rogers America's a spokesman as Drax the
destroyer
I see that at all actually originally
auditioned for a different role for the
part of Drax the destroyer in guardians
of the galaxy Oh
ala we're going to Dave Bautista who's
done a wonderful job with the character
bowsman is a great actor and I'm not so
sure his style would have no comedic
tone of the Guardians movie and the
drags character I want to see that on
addition to Bozeman was probably upset
when he didn't get the part
seeing as he was just coming off a
leading role in 42 as jackie robinson's
ultimately it all worked out for the
best he didn't get to play drags but he
ended up in the MCU regardless yeah
that's a much better role my role in a
massive blockbuster movie we can't help
but wonder what the Drax character would
have been like if Bozeman got the part
it would certainly be weird but nowhere
near as weird if dave bautista played
the cella nebula I could see that almost
played other parts did you know that
Lupita Nyong'o originally auditioned for
the role of nebula she stabbed first
guardians of the galaxy movie Buddha
Morris what a different you know
originally tried joining the Marvel
Universe much sooner than her debut in
Black Panther as Nakia she had just
finished her future awesome that it
matters law that made years of slave
joke was me she didn't get the part as a
wince to Karen Gillan but that worked
out for all parties because Nia was one
of the highlights of black panther Karen
Gillan as Sharon Carter speaking of
nebula that's not that Karen Gillan
originally eared you've got a much
better roll man fascinating the Winter
Soldier she had met with Marvel and
auditioned to be the captain's new love
in time she was wrapping up her time on
Doctor Who as the character Amy Pond
ultimately Gillan didn't get the part as
it wants to Emily Venter
kind of looks like Emily VanCamp karen
gillan
also what's the deal with marvel's
casting process karen gillan will finish
Aaron Carter but instead they gave her
nebula Lupita Nyong'o wanted to play
nebula so instead they gave her Nakia
isn't just a never-ending process of
moving someone over to the next
available role Tom Hiddleston asked oh
yeah there's like audition what I just
wanted to think about on the whole list
Tom Hiddleston is famous for playing the
role of Loki Thor's mischievious and
sometimes downright evil little brother
he plays such an iconic role it's almost
uncomfortable to think about it Olsen
playing the part of Thor when Hiddleston
went in for his audition for the movie
trying out for the lead role Marvel did
some screen time with him and even had
him sport blond hair and his hammer mill
near of course they eventually went with
Chris Hemsworth for the role but
Hiddleston left such a lasting
impression that they brought him aboard
as Loki instead he's since proven to be
a fan favorite and one of the most
integral parts of the MCU Sebastian Stan
this is another one that just feels icky
to visualize we all know what it is like
just wait and you're viewing this wanted
the river casting director Sarah Finn
felt that he was bringing too much
darkness to the delivery that just
wasn't right for the role of the cat
still she was impressed by what she saw
and suggested Stan played the role of
Bucky Barnes in their next Captain
America installment and the rest was his
I mean even the first Captain America
Stan's character will actually be
spending a longer time in the MCU than
Captain America as if Air Force goes to
show how important and useful it is that
Marvel plans out their movies so far in
advance
this way they can keep an eye on
potential talent for future role
that aren't even being casted for yet
anthony mackie as mandarin the role of
Sam Wilson has been famously portrayed
by Anthony Mackie while the character
isn't one of the original Avengers and
doesn't have his own standalone movie to
speak of he's still one of the most
important Cabernets part of Falcon and
winter so did you know that Anthony
Mackie originally intended on playing a
bad guy his first audition during the
role would ultimately go depend Kingsley
which really makes me wonder what the
casting call looks like yeah while
Anthony Mackie was auditioning to play
the Mandarin it was Michael B Jordan who
was auditioning to play the Falcon
fortunately he wouldn't get hard and
would go on to join the MCU that next a
Louis role Eric jmeter in Black Panther
while Michael B Jordan probably would
have been great in the role of Falcon as
well it was probably for the best
in fact that first time appearing in the
Marvel Universe in 2015 he played the
Human Torch in the Fantastic Four a
movie that was a historical earlier
while it was a Marvel movie it didn't
exist within the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that we know today and it's a
good thing people barely remember that
Fantastic Four no I don't think I barely
remembered the actor he's funny he's
talented man I think a man delivers in
any role he plays I could say a weird
version of that couldn't see before
Downey jr. Wallace just perfect for the
role Rockwell been the lead role and
been the one to kickstart the MCU way
back in 2008 there's just no telling
with a friend could see a man more slimy
snarky started using him as Justin
Hammer in Iron Man 2 the role of Justin
Hammer was meant to be a Tony Stark
wannabe with a very similar attitude
only you know bad
who wanted to be star-lord Djimon Honsou
interesting because there were several
beginning actors in the running to play
star-lord before the part went to Chris
Pratt in fact three of the actors listen
as chakras SK playing different under
mine first off Lee pace auditioned to
play instead he ended up getting cast in
the rodent only to play the film's
antagonist Ronan the accuser
imagine going in to audition for a part
and end up being cast as the characters
opposition God isn't it Hayes wasn't the
only Marvel actor to try out for the
role as Michael Rosenbaum alright
Rosenbaum is a close personal friend of
guardians of the galaxy to right here in
the MCU he had a leg up on the
competition of course the role would
eventually got Chris Pratt
no don't found a way to utilize his
buddy casting him to play on Martin acts
in the guardians of the galaxy vol 2
Zachary Levi was another actor who tried
out for the role of star-lord he didn't
get the part but he was eventually cast
to replace Josh Dallas in the role of
Fandral into Thor the dark world Thor
the dark world Levi would go on to get
his lead role in a superhero movie
starring in 2019 Shazam other actors who
were seriously considered for the role
of Peter quele included Joel Edgerton
Jim Sturgess Jack Hudson and Eddie
Redmayne all that to say good for Chris
Pratt I can't imagine anyone else doing
star-lord has Jake Gyllenhaal wanted to
be a part of the MCU for quite some time
and it makes sense he's a bonafide alien
stalker subtract his acting chops why
shouldn't he land a prominent Ron
Mysterio sport escape choice of all time
seemingly every big name celebrity Under
the Sun plays at corresponding superhero
it almost didn't make sense the likeable
popular good guy Jake Gyllenhaal didn't
have one
according to reports he was very close
to playing the role of dr. strange okay
these are all like his heart would
eventually go to Benedict comes back
none of the darker roles are looking at
wonderful job Gyllenhaal is a great area
there's no telling if and how we could
have tops Cumberbatch's masterful
performance and don't feel too bad for
jakey boy either
he ended up getting his MCU part
portraying the role of Mysterio in
spider-man far from home
we'll see him in that role on the big
screen again is still up in the air it's
crazy to think how drastically different
the MCU acts slowly casting choices
we're glad things worked out the way
they did though which one of these
entries do you wish actually happened
would you like to see not totally cool
with the way things are done let us know
which one you'd be most curious to check
out in the comment section below
Chadwick Boseman is treks yeah
none of them compared to the strangest
that was the hell would take an anthony
mackie Mandarin and Anthony back to rim
that's pretty weird sure yeah although
it would be more fun to see Chadwick
Drax yeah
Drex wick Bozeman dick Marvel that's
such a perfect job with who they usually
put in the roles that it's very
difficult for me to imagine them as
other people it's like I could see an
audition tape in mind for a lot of them
like Sam Rockwell is Tony Stark
that means answer the question no I I
don't think any of them would be better
in any of these roles per se like Lupita
Nyong'o as nebula I could see a version
of that where that really works because
nebula was a character that didn't
really care for till way later like it
took me a woah not even buy guardians
volume to it wasn't so like endgame if
any your infinity horror I was like yeah
I like nebula yeah I could see the pizza
and younger doing that especially
working off a zoe saldana that could
work Karen Gilliam really lucked out
though with getting nebula instead of
Sharon Carter because the Sharon Carter
character is not really all that popular
you gotta like people who are like
really invested EMC to remember who
Sharon Carter is I think and yeah I mean
the Sharon Carter character just kind of
seemed to be like a weird thing well
it's having to get to that kiss scene in
Civil War I know in the comics they do
strike up a romance but at the same time
the way how it just kind of gets there
in the movie you're like it's a little
strange but yeah the Sharon Carr here
there's not nowhere near as memorable as
a nebula character to put it lightly and
also Lupita nyong'o's character and
black panther it's only been one movie
so I think by the time we get like a
black panther 2 or whatever crossover
comes up should probably be more
memorable that one one thing this really
clued me into is how sharp and succinct
their casting is because what this kind
of showed was you have a lot of these
people who are similar types or
kind of can fill similar shoes but these
characters have such specificity a few
shades different makes all the
difference yes oh yeah it's like Chris
Pratt and Chris Evans you know like I
can see why they both would be held up
for Captain America the personality that
extra trait of you know everyman up
standing is that Chris Evans has you
really really I think have to give it to
Kevin fighting the whole casting crew
yeah because they find the people with
the right amount of weight the right
personality to match with these
characters and yeah it's fascinating to
see the ones where you're like Sam
Rockwell that could work but it would be
just different enough that I don't think
the emcee would be what it is if it was
him I mean the Captain America can't
auditioning is funny to me because Chris
Evans was courted so many times he kept
refusing the role they're like
auditioning people in between but it
just seems like what they really wanted
was Chris Evans to say yes Chris Pratt I
could see him doing it but it wouldn't
be perfect Sebastian Stan I love the
comment here about how he was just
delivering it at two tre okay yeah it's
Sebastian Stan look at it everything
about her how there's a darkness behind
his eyes yeah he's got a natural
darkness about him so I could see why
that could be a bit of an off-putting
thing because everybody appears in the
Captain America the First Avenger just
Sebastian stand the way he looks there
is darkness there just shows up and is
dark yeah but Chadwick Boseman is Drax
I'd love to see that version because I
think a scape imagining body type like
yeah
Drax I always imagined as a big bulky
character or Chadwick Boseman well he
liked bulked up for Black Panther it's
still nowhere near like a Dave boat he's
taller than he is
yeah and I feel like you can do comedy
Chadwick Boseman
Black Panther is such a serious role
that it's hard to envision the comedic
sensibilities but you know he gets a
little bit of loose and get on up you
know he's playing James Brown in that
movie said he gets a little bit looser
you play James Brown you gotta be
willing to goof off a little bit Tom
Hiddleston is Thor I think that he got
very lucky because as beloved as Thor is
now he didn't really start receiving
that love until Ragnarok
people liked him I think but the Chris
Hemsworth that we loved as the work
didn't kick in till Ragnarok time
whereas Loki has been holding it down
yeah you know before the first event or
the dark world people were like oh you
smell great now Loki's great you know
like there's a reason Loki's getting his
own show now yeah I know he's been dead
and everything in between I mean Michael
B Jordan as Falcon you can see it it's
one of those where it just doesn't seem
quite as succinct and I do like Anthony
Mackie a lot I like him in the role I
like his chemistry with Chris Evans I
feel like Falcon is a roll out of all
these that you could maybe go different
with and it wouldn't change the entire
foundation of the character but I do
think Michael B Jordan is kind of
similar to Sebastian Stannis cap in that
scenario to me I'm like there's
something a little bit more menacing
than Mike than Anthony Mackie well I
think Michael B Jordan got much more of
a dark edge like Anthony Mackie is great
in in hardcore dramas first movie I ever
saw it was actually eight-mile Anthony
Mackie can definitely do like gravitas
in there like a lot of depth but he also
has a lot of comedy in his and his
background and I think that goes really
well to serve the Falcon character same
time it's like I wouldn't want to see
Anthony Mackie as kill monger I feel
like he'd probably do it but Michael B
Jordan edges him out and I would say the
same for Falcon like Michael B Jordan is
edged out by Anthony Mackie even though
I think Michael B Jordan could pull it
off
Terrence Howard should play both yeah
and Jake Gyllenhaal as Doctor Strange
weirdly out of all of these I mean under
than like Chadwick Boseman
as Drax and Anthony Mackie as Mandarin
the hardest one for me to imagine is
Jake Gyllenhaal is Doctor Strange it
seems like something on paper that
should just click in my brain but
Benedict Cumberbatch is just so perfect
and so specific of her portrayal because
he's not behaving like Benedict
Cumberbatch he you know he's got a bit
you got a very specific way of
delivering his lines and the voice that
he does and the body language the
specific portrayal that Benedict
Cumberbatch nailed down I have a hard
time imagining Jellico's Jake Gyllenhaal
wouldn't just show up and be Jake
Gyllenhaal he'd do something very
specific sound like what's that
specificity that Jake Gyllenhaal would
do whatever he whether he brings would
be very unique and very engaging I'm
sure but yeah it's another one I can
almost see it but it doesn't click
because Benedict Cumberbatch just has
that kind of surgeon he has that sort of
affluent quality is that like a
hyper-intelligent quality about him yeah
this is natural to his
Jake Gyllenhaal I think is just again
you see him and I think he could play
somebody obviously Mysterio is pretty
brilliant in the mind but you know I
feel like he could play a Doctor Strange
type but I feel like there would be more
Tony Stark in it than needs to be
because like they're similar characters
but yeah I don't know Jake Gyllenhaal I
think would need to be older for me
before he could do that yeah well I
think he also bows down to the relation
even though it's not like the biggest
deal out of the movie he's got a passel
of relationship with Christine in Doctor
Strange Richard McAdams character and I
feel like with Jake Gyllenhaal and
Rachel McAdams are like well yeah of
course they want a pony that's what it
is
Jake Gyllenhaal has to work to make
himself look strange ah true whereas dr.
Mraz Benedict Cumberbatch has a bit of a
strange thing about him he's got
interesting face so it feels like
aptly-named
before him like you know yeah I'll never
forget the first time I saw Benedict
Cumberbatch I had to comprehend his head
and also like the hair it all fits
better
there's none canny
thing that Marvel's casting people are
able to nail down which thus far for the
most part has been preeminent but then
one might argue Jake Gyllenhaal looks
nothing like winning back from the
comics either okay how are they also
tweaking the interpretations and
marrying them to people well I mean this
is a fun list man I didn't know like it
said 80% of these I didn't know if
you're going out of ten 80% I did not
know I only knew two yeah guys what any
of these which one would you have been
most fascinated to have checked out or
which one do you think might have
actually outdone the performer who has
cast leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
thank you to screening as make sure to
subscribe and then last but not least
Maria Hammond the last couple shadows
we've given you I know we've leaned a
little bit more into the jokey written
side I wanted to just be here today to
tell you I've only known you for a short
while now like two or three months at
this point didn't know you has just been
an absolute delight you are so like
there's so much rich character the way
you talk with me you're so expressive
there's so much compassion behind the
way you express yourself Josh is lucky
to have you as mom I think that you have
been someone who's been undeniably sweet
this entire
I love the extra mile you go to with
checking out content of ours that a lot
of people don't know check out and
supporting us on other platforms as well
if we do other collapse I'm very happy
to know you very happy to have you here
and I know the last time I charged you
out you're like I just pledged this
amount to show support you didn't even
want a shout out so I figured I just
take time today to say thank you and
keep being yourself because as much
cynicism as you say you have you project
nothing but positivity our way thank you